HONORING VETERANS GO TO
FOXNEWS.COM, TO SIGN UP NOW.
>> Joey: BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CAN REPEAL THE POLICY MANY SAY
IS NECESSARY TO SECURE THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> SUPREME COURT HAS SET STAGE
FOR INVENTIVIZATION AND JOE
BIDEN WANTS HIS DHS TO KNOW
GRANT CITIZENSHIP TO
PHILLIP:EL WHO HAVE ILLEGALLY
ENTERED THIS COUNTRY.
>> Carley: LARA TRUMP JOINS US,
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
SUPREME COURT RULE SOMETHING
>> A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES AND
PEOPLE WHO  BELIEVE IN THIS ARE
NOT THRILLED WITH THIS DECISION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE CAN SPORTS THAT
THE SUPREME COURT IS FOLLOWING
THE LAWS -- TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
POURING OVER THE BORDER, YOU
HEARD IT THERE, THAT IS RIGHT.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE SO MANY MORE
PEOPLE, WE HAVE HAD RECORD
NUMBERS COMING OVER THE BORDER,
IT WILL FURTHER INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO COME HERE, THEY KNOW
THE POLICY IS GONE AND NOT
COMING BACK, WHEN YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THINGS AND YOU LOOK AT
THE FACT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HASN'T BEEN
ENFORCING THE LAW AND ARE EAGER
TO GET READY OF THE REMAIN IN
MEXICO POLICY, WHICH DID A GREAT
JOB OF DETERRING PEOPLE FROM
COMING HERE, IT ONLY FURTHER
PROVES THEY ARE CONDONE
ING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND
ENCOURAGING IT TO HAPPEN WITHIN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, IT IS
DANGEROUS FOR PEOPLE COMING
HERE, WE SAW 53 PEOPLE DEAD IN
THE BACK OF THE TRUCK, A THIRD
OF WOMEN ARE ASSAULTED NORTH OF
THE SOUTHERN BORDER, SOMETHING
WE SHOULD NEVER BE ENCOURAGING,
I THINK THAT IS AFFECT AND
IMPACT THIS DECISION WILL HAVE,
NOT GREAT FOR AMERICA OR
IMMIGRANTS TRYING TO COME HERE.
>> Joey: LET'S TURN ON TO THIS,
HOUSE DEMOCRATS PUTTING A BILL
OF RIGHTS AHEAD OF ELECTION.
IT WOULD GUARANTEE RIGHT TO
ABORTION, ALLOW STUDENTS TO JOIN
SPORTS TEAMS AND GENDER
AFFIRMING MEDICAL CARE, LARA,
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANYONE
WHO DISAGREES WITH EVERY
AMERICAN BEING TREATED EQUALLY,
FAIRLY AND RESPECTFULLY, BUT YOU
SEE SO MANY ITEMS THAT ARE
CONTAINED WITHIN THIS AND
OBVIOUSLY THAT DOES NOT REFLECT
THE SENTIMENT OF MOST AMERICANS
AND AT A TIME IN AMERICA, YOU
HAVE PEOPLE STRUGGLING JUST TO
MAKE ENDS MEET AND GET BY, THE
FACT ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
FOCUSED ON THIS, SUCH A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF OUR POPULATION,
THE TRANS COMMUNITY, IT IS
FRUSTRATING TO SO MANY PEOPLE TO
THINK, WHY AREN'T THEY FOCUSED
ON FIXING THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE
PART OF DAY-TO-DAY LIVES LIKE
GAS PRICES AND INFLATION AND
ETCETERA INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON
THINGS LIKE THIS.
THERE IS REAL FRUSTRATION THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND A LOT OF
LEADERS IN WASHINGTON ARE NOT
REPRESENTING THE VAST MAJORITY
OF US AND DOING THINGS THAT WILL
HELP US IN DAY-TO-DAY LIVES.
>> Carley: HOW ARE YOU
CELEBRATING 4TH OF JULY THIS
WEEKEND?
>> WE'RE DOING WHAT A LOT OF
>> WE ARE DOING WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE DOING.
UNFORTUNATELY EVERYBODY IS GOING
TO BE PAYING A LITTLE MORE
DESPITE WHAT YOU HAD LAST YEAR
FROM THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
BUT WE ARE GOING TO CELEBRAT